(perky music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler, of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is Nobel
laureate Linus Pauling.
Dr. Pauling received the
Nobel Prize in chemistry
in 1954, and the Nobel
Peace Prize in 1963.
He is visiting the
Berkeley campus this week
to deliver the Hitchcock Lectures,
and our topic for today's discussion
is the peace movement in
historical perspective.
Dr. Pauling, welcome to Berkeley.
- Well, thank you.
- I wonder if you might for us recall
the early days of the peace movement
right after the First World
War, of the Second World War.
You were a member of
Einstein's Emergency Committee
of Atomic Scientists, one
of the really first efforts.
- That's right, I got interested
in world peace, really, in 1945.
I had been working during
the Second World War,
for a little while earlier than that,
a year or two earlier, on war projects.
I still was professor
chairman of the division
of chemistry and chemical engineering
in the California Institute of Technology,
but I had about 20 contracts with
the Office of Scientific
Research and Development.
Oppenheimer asked me to come to Los Alamos
as the head of the chemistry section
of the atomic bomb project,
and I decided not to do it.
I had so much going on in Pasadena,
including continuing teaching chemistry
and this large amount for our work.
When the atomic bombs
were dropped, exploded
over Hiroshima and Nagasaki in 1945,
I was very soon asked
by some service club,
Rotary Club in Hollywood, to talk about
nuclear fission, about the
nature of these weapons.
I was able to do so because
I had not been connected
with the Atomic Energy Project
and had no classified
information about these weapons.
So I began giving talks to, popular talks
to groups of that sort, which
were purely educational,
descriptive in nature, with
little political content.
Rather soon, they began to
involve also an expression
of my own ideas, and I don't
remember just how early
it was that I was able
to quote Albert Einstein
as saying that now that a
single bomb, atomic bomb
can destroy a whole
city, and a single rocket
can lob it over, the time has
come when we must give up war,
but then I was asked to
join the board of trustees
of the Einstein committee,
the Emergency Committee
of Atomic Scientists, which consisted
only of the board of trustees,
half a dozen scientists.
Albert Einstein as chairman,
and Harold Urey as vice chairman.
So every few months, I went
with my wife to Princeton
to a meeting of this board and later on,
I took, made, began making lecture tours
partially along with Leo Szilard.
We would show a film which
the committee had had made,
probably the first film
about atomic bombs,
explaining what nuclear war
would be, just the little
atomic bombs, Hiroshima
and Nagasaki type then.
And Leo Szilard would give a
talk, and I would speak too
about the necessity to understand
what had happened in the world
now that the means of
waging war had changed
in such an astounding way.
- And very early on, you
were advocating against
the production of the hydrogen
bomb, even in the late 40s.
- Well, tried, I opposed the construction
of the hydrogen bomb on the, I think,
rather reasonable grounds
that an ordinary atomic bomb
could destroy a whole city,
and even the biggest cities,
it could do much damage,
perhaps kill a million people
out of the 10 million in a large city,
and that there was no need to make,
to accelerate the arms
race by developing weapons
a thousand times more powerful.
- How important was
the fact that you were,
and had not really been
in government service?
Do you think that made
it easier for you to draw
some of these conclusions and
to speak publicly about them?
- Yes, well of course, I had, in a sense,
been in government service in the,
I took leave one summer from
the Institute in order to go
to the Central Explosives
Research Laboratory.
- [Harry] This would
be during the war, or?
- During the war, during the war.
And I had a large number
of government contracts
that I was responsible for,
but I didn't have classified
information about atomic bombs,
and I could talk about them
as freely as I wanted, I thought.
After my first talk, I
think, the second day
after my first talk, an FBI
man turned up in my office
and said, "How did you,
who gave you information
"about how much plutonium
or uranium-235 there is
"in an atomic bomb?"
And I said, "Nobody, I figured it out."
(Harry laughing)
So, I wasn't bothered thereafter,
but if I had had classified information,
we can see that I might
well have been restrained
from speaking in public about the need
to get control over war the
way that I was speaking.
- And over the next decade and a half,
both you and your wife were very active
in lecturing, in holding conferences
and petitioning the government
and making known to the public, really,
the issues involved in these new weapons?
- Yes, that's right.
My wife had been interested
in social, political
and economic problems ever
since she was a teenage girl.
She used to argue with, in Salem, Oregon,
where she was going to high school,
with a friend of the
family, one of the judges
of the Oregon State Supreme Court,
of which my uncle became
a chief justice later on.
She didn't know him until after, look,
she did actually know him
before we were married.
He was a friend of her family
in Oregon City, Oregon.
- But she, I gather, was very supportive
and, in fact, would direct
a lot of her speeches
to the women's perspective
on these issues, is that--
- Yes, that's right, and
of course, I have said
and I have to say that
I'm sure that if I had not
married her, I would not have
had that aspect of my career
that I have had, of
working for world peace.
It was her influence on me
and her continued support
that caused me to continue.
In fact, I have said that
during the McCarthy period,
when many people, especially scientists
who had been following
approximately the same course
that I was following, gave up.
I continued, because I had to
retain the respect of my wife.
- And what drove her?
Was it her academic
background, or her kind
of humanistic concerns
about the fate of the world?
- Well, I think largely,
her humanistic concerns.
She had had some training as a chemist,
and during the Second World War she worked
for a couple of years as
assistant to Professor Haagen-Smit
on a war project of
developing guayule rubber.
She worked as a chemist, but
her, and she had an interest,
general interest, in
science and was very able,
very smart, but she was really concerned
about human beings, the humanistic concern
that she had was very great.
- And in the lectures that you both gave,
they were very similar to
what we're seeing today
being done by the Physicians
for Social Responsibility
on a larger scale, I mean, an exposure
of the public to, really,
the horrors of nuclear war
in ways that they had never seen.
- Yes, but when you say on a larger scale,
I'm not even sure of that,
because we gave hundreds
of lectures about world peace.
And there were other
people too, Norman Cousins
giving a great number of lectures.
There was great activity
25 years ago in this field.
- Right, and one of the petitions
that was signed by 52 Nobel Prize winners,
the Mainau Document of July 15th, 1955,
I noticed there was a
sentence that in the petition
we think it is a delusion
if governments believe
that they can avoid war for a long time
through the fear of these weapons.
All nations must come to the decision
to renounce force as a
final resort of policy.
Was that a criticism of
deterrents of the notion
of deterrence that was emerging, or--
- Well, it may be that it
was, I wasn't at Mainau
that year, I have gone to
Mainau where their meetings
of Nobel laureates from
time, every year, in fact.
I wasn't there, I signed this statement,
but I wasn't involved in writing it.
I believe and I continue to believe
that the deterrent
effect of nuclear weapons
is very important.
Here, in 1961, the Soviet Union
exploded in the atmosphere
a single three stage
nuclear weapon that was a 60 megaton bomb
with explosive power equal
to 60 million tons of TNT.
That's 10 times the explosive
power of all of the bombs
used in the whole of the Second World War,
in this one explosion,
and these bombs exist
by the thousands, not so many,
I don't know that there are
any other 60 megaton bombs,
because there's no target worthy of one,
but there are 20 megaton bombs,
and many one megaton bombs around,
roughly equal to the Second
World War in a single bomb.
The feeling that I had
and many other people,
that the existence of these stockpiles
of terribly destructive
weapons that if used
would certainly destroy
civilization as we know it
and might well wipe out the human race,
meant that the great powers
must not get involved
in a war with one another.
My own feeling, then
and now, is as expressed
in the report by the Boston
Group, Philip Morrison
and his associates,
and their report called
The Price of Defense,
issued about four years ago,
is that the nuclear
deterrent should be reduced
from its present completely insane level
to a somewhat less irrational level.
But I think we don't, we
shouldn't get rid of it entirely
and tempt the great powers to
go back to old fashioned wars
with one another, with
conventional weapons
and with 20 million people killed
in the First World War, 40
million in the Second World War,
perhaps 60 million or 80
million in the Third World War
fought with conventional weapons.
Why take that chance?
Well, I believe in the nuclear deterrent,
but it's just got out
of hand, and we continue
to waste money on it
instead of stabilizing it.
- Were charges made against you
that you were for unilateral disarmament?
I mean, in a public
debate, there tends to be
such a distortion of views
that are so different
from the conventional wisdom,
as yours were in the 50s.
- Yes, I think that there were some
irresponsible statements about me,
to the effect that I was working
for disarming the United States,
that I was taken in by Soviet propaganda
and that sort of thing, and, of course,
I was speaking out for awhile,
contrary to the official opinion.
If we had had a dictatorship
in this country,
I might well have been
accused of the crime
of seditious libel, which is used
in dictatorships to suppress criticism.
Seditious libel consists
in making statements
critical of government policy,
that's sedition in a dictatorship.
Well, you know, when I was
awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
in 1963, Life magazine
published an editorial
with the heading, A
Weird Insult from Norway,
the Norwegian Nobel Committee
awards the Peace Prizes.
Well, this, I think that
the writer of this editorial
thought that it was insulting
to give the Peace Prize
to someone who advocated something
that was not the official policy
of the United States government.
- And indeed, when you
circulated a '58 petition,
which was signed by 2,000
American scientists,
and I think 8,000 foreign scientists,
from 49 different countries,
there was a government
harassment, there was
harassment in the press of you
for undertaking this effort, really,
and charges of working
for the enemy, really,
is that not correct?
- Well, to some extent, yes.
And I was given, I first announced
that 2,000 American scientists
had signed the petition
asking for a cessation of the testing
of nuclear weapons in the atmosphere
where they were liberating
radioactive fallout
over the whole world that
would cause defective children
to be born and to damage
living people too,
living human beings, causing
cancer and other diseases.
We asked that the
nations make an agreement
to stop the testing of nuclear weapons.
At that time, the government policy
was not to make this treaty,
it had not yet been decided,
but pretty soon it was
decided to make such a treaty.
I think that I got a good bit of support,
but some criticism also.
Here I had written this petition together
with Barry Commoner and Ed Condon.
Ed Condon is a Berkeley
man who was, at that time,
professor of physics in
Washington University,
Barry Commoner, professor of biology
in Washington University, St. Louis.
We circulated the petition.
I decided later to, well,
people from foreign countries,
scientists from foreign countries,
began to send in copies,
signed copies of the petition.
So my wife and I circulated
it in foreign countries
and ultimately, turned over
15,000 signatures of scientists
to the Secretary General Dag Hammarskjold
of the United Nations.
- And on another occasion
when you were in the
Soviet Union you actually
wrote a letter to
Khrushchev which included
a draft treaty, which I
gather was very similar
to the partial test ban which
was eventually adapted in '63?
- Yes, yes, I didn't get to
talk with Premier Khrushchev
then, there was an
appointment set up for me,
and then it was canceled,
and it's hard to know
why things of this sort are done,
but in fact, in 1961, which
is when this occurred,
my wife and I asked, we were there
for a scientific congress,
biochemical congress,
but we said we would like to speak
at a peace meeting, a public meeting.
The Soviet Peace Committee put out posters
announcing the meeting and we went to it,
in the Hall, the Hall of
the Scientists in Moscow
that holds a thousand people.
We had a film along, the Peace Movement
in Southern California,
showing a demonstration.
Two or three thousand
people, perhaps more,
marching with banners
and meeting in a park
and my speaking to them,
and then my wife talked
and then I talked, and I said,
"The Soviet Union has just exploded
"this 60 megaton bomb, and that, I think,
"I estimate will cause a
million children to be born
"over a course of generations,
because these gene mutations
"last, are passed on, a million children
"to be born with gross
physical or mental defect
"that would not have
been defective otherwise,
"and will cause, perhaps,
just as many people
"to develop cancer and other disease,
"and I think it's immoral, unethical
"for nations to do this
damage to the human race."
I think that was the last atomic bomb
that they exploded, but I'm not sure.
At any rate, the bomb
test treaty negotiations
were going on and very quickly, next year,
the treaty was signed
and it went into effect
in October of 1963.
- The Nobel Committee, in
awarding you the Peace Prize,
pointed out that the language
that President Kennedy used
in his speech announcing the signing
of the partial test ban was very similar
to the language that you
had used in defining,
they did, in fact, the
language you just used
in describing your speech
in the Soviet Union.
- Yes, yeah.
- Was this an instance of
power listening to science?
- I think so.
There was a meeting, a
dinner that President Kennedy
and Mrs. Kennedy held for
recipients of the Nobel Prize
in the Western Hemisphere
and some of their people.
And on the day before, my wife and I,
and on the day of the meeting, in fact,
had demonstrated outside the White House
against the bomb tests.
- [Harry] This would've been in what year?
- In 1961, I think, possibly 1960.
We, when we came through
the reception line,
Mrs. Kennedy, after
shaking hands with me said,
"Do you think it is right, Dr. Pauling,
"to march back and forth with your sign
"outside the White House?"
So that Caroline says to me, "Mommy,
"what has Daddy done wrong now?"
(Harry laughs)
And then she introduced
me to President Kennedy,
who said, "Dr. Pauling, I
hope that you will continue
"to express your opinions."
And, of course, I think that
it was about at that time
that he became convinced
that the atmospheric testing
of bomb, nuclear weapons, was
really the wrong thing to do
and began applying political pressure
to the Senate to approve
the test ban treaty,
well, began deciding to
instruct his negotiators to sign
the test ban treaty.
- Do you think
if he had lived that the
progress on arms control
would have been more significant,
since he had gone through this process
of negotiating this treaty,
and then, of course,
he had gone through the
Cuban Missile Crisis.
- The Cuban Missile, yes, well,
he, I think he had a real
understanding of the significance
of nuclear weapons and
a very great concern
for his responsibility, and of course,
I believe that he admired
Khrushchev for his restraint.
They handled that missile crisis well.
I think he could understand
that if the United States
had weapons, the feeling by Khrushchev
and the other Soviet leaders,
that if the United States
had rockets armed with nuclear warheads
in Turkey and other places
close to the Soviet Union,
why shouldn't the Soviet
Union put them in Cuba?
But, of course, it was
the wrong thing to do.
It's good that there was some restraint
over the spread of nuclear weapons.
- Why has it been so
difficult to bridge this gap
between the insights of scientists
and the thinking and actions
of our political leaders?
Because if you go through this history
of the peace movement in the 50s,
it's as if we're reliving
all of this again today.
- That's right, it looks as though
we haven't learned anything
from recent history
of 25 years ago when the hydrogen bomb,
the three stage bomb had been developed.
The weapons became, the
individual bombs, warheads,
became a thousand times more powerful
than the Hiroshima-Nagasaki bombs.
10 or 20,000 times more powerful
than the one ton
blockbusters with which most
of the bombings were done
in the Second World War.
The stockpiles had already
become irrationally great
25 years ago, the analysts all talked
about a 10,000 megaton
attack on the United States
and a 10,000 megaton
counterattack on the Soviet Union
and were making estimates
about, perhaps 80% of the people
would be dead 60 days after the attack.
So that the situation now
is we still talk about
10,000 megaton attacks, it
hasn't changed very much
in that respect, the need
for detente was clear,
and of course, we went through
a period of a number of years
when the relationship was better,
but there was still, there
were still changes being made
in the development of nuclear weapons.
Usually, with the United
States taking the lead,
just as we had a five year lead initially
on building atomic bombs.
We introduced the idea of, well,
the anti-ballistic
missile, this development
along these lines was stopped by a treaty.
That was one case where
a good treaty was made
between the United States
and the Soviet Union.
The idea of MIRV, multiple independently
directable re-entry vehicles
with nuclear warheads
so that a single big
rocket, instead of carrying
a 20 megaton bomb that
would essentially destroy
Moscow or any other city,
could be made more effective
because there aren't
many 20 megaton targets.
Instead, it could carry,
perhaps 16 small rockets,
each with its own one megaton bomb,
20 or 25 times as big as a
Hiroshima or Nagasaki bomb,
big enough for most
cities, and with computers
and programmed in such a way
that 16 different targets
could be destroyed, and a few years later,
the Soviet Union also, they
haven't quite caught up
with us on MIRVing their big rockets,
but they're well on their way.
So, now we have the cruise missile,
and I heard Andropov speak.
I was in Moscow the 21st of
December, three weeks ago,
when a month, nearly a month ago
when Andropov gave his
talk in which he said
that they were willing to cut
down on intermediate range
missiles to the number that the West had,
Britain, France, the United States,
and would continue to cut down
if we were willing to cut down.
But he went on to become very tough then,
I suppose he has to,
under the circumstances,
with a tough opponent
in the United States,
and he said that they
were well on their way
toward completing the development
of their own cruise
missile, if we went ahead
with our 7,000 cruise missiles.
Very dangerous business,
they would soon have an equal number.
- So the race has gone on.
- And they're going to--
- And it--
- Yes, he said
they would keep up with us, of course,
Reagan, President Reagan
says we'll keep ahead
of the Soviet Union.
What is going to happen
if these two great nations
are not able to get enough
sense to stop this waste
of money and this increasing of the danger
of a nuclear war breaking out?
As these weapons become
and the delivery vehicles,
the whole system, become
more and more complicated,
the chance that there
will be a technological
or psychological accident that initiates
the catastrophic interchange
of these terribly destructive
weapons becomes greater and greater,
so that we get in more and more danger
that a nuclear war will break out.
When the world is destroyed,
it'll be by accident,
not by design, not by this direct decision
of Reagan or Andropov, but by accident.
- Why then have the politicians,
the political leaders on both sides
failed to heed the warnings
about these dangers?
When one goes through this history
or reads your very good book, No More War,
published in 1958, you
find that the issues
have been on the table since
early times in this new era.
- The arguments in my book
are essentially the same.
I talked about a 20,000 megaton bomb war,
20,000 megaton war, 10,000
from each side there,
and that's what we still talk about,
and the other dangers and
the need for making the world
a safer place, the arguments
are still just as good
25 years after this book was published.
And why haven't we got control?
Well, the Soviet Union, first, the people
and the government fear war,
they don't want to have a war.
They are afraid, also, of
attack by the Western powers.
They are afraid of the
anti-communism that we know exists,
upon the express statement that we
are out to destroy communism.
And they are more afraid than we are,
because they know what war is.
There were 50 times as many
people in the Soviet Union
killed in the Second
World War as Americans
killed in the Second World War.
They experienced the destruction
of their own country.
So, I think that they
feel that they have to try
to keep up with the United States
and not tempt our militarists.
Now, our position has
been made pretty clear,
year after year, or decade
after decade from 30 years ago,
that our gross national product
is twice that of the Soviet Union.
We fear communism, that communism
will take over the world.
Well, as Khrushchev said,
"They say communism is so good
"a system that it's
inevitable that it take over."
And we don't agree with
that, so we fear communism
and think that we must
prevent the takeover.
Our, we are twice as
affluent as the Soviet Union,
have twice the gross national
product of the Soviet Union.
The burden of militarism,
even if it were great for us
would be twice as great for them.
President Reagan issued, a few months ago,
a national security directive that repeats
the statement that we must
apply economic pressure,
military pressure, diplomatic pressure,
propagandistic pressure
on the Soviet Union
with the hope of eliminating
it from the world.
In fact, he said to the,
in June, I think it was,
he spoke to the British
Parliament in London
and said that by applying this pressure,
we, ultimately shall achieve
the goal of leaving Marxism, Leninism
on the ash heap of history.
I'm quoting President Reagan.
So we have a goal, that
of applying pressure
by increasing military expenditures
until finally they become
intolerable for the Soviet Union.
I read one statement by a commentator
back in Connecticut who said,
"President Reagan's plan, that by spending
"our spending 1.6 trillion dollars
"on militarism in the next five years,
"to bankrupt the Soviet Union,
already in its first year
"has come close, has
brought the United States
"to the verge of bankruptcy,
not only economically,
"but also morally and spiritually."
- So that what the
politicians didn't learn
from the scientists was
to go beyond this notion
that victory is still possible,
is that what you're suggesting?
I mean, that they believe
that by building up
nuclear weapons they can,
not necessarily have to go
to nuclear war, but will be in a position
to keep the other party down, and then,
by simultaneously
applying economic screws,
possibly even break the system,
so that the politicians
haven't really gotten over
these old ways of thinking that Einstein
and others warned, they really
would have to move beyond.
- That's right, they haven't recognized
that this is just too
dangerous a policy to follow,
And I am sure that President Reagan
and his advisors do not anticipate
that there will be a nuclear war.
I'm sure that they don't
believe the statement
that they made last year,
that we might carry on
a militant nuclear war in Europe
and still not destroy the world.
I'm sure they don't believe that.
That was just propaganda
to get the American people
to accept the whole idea of
continuing the military buildup
and the increase in the
military budget at the same time
that we are having trouble
with the parts of the budget
that relate to the wellbeing
of the American people.
This is just propaganda, they don't think
that we can have, I have said that well,
perhaps limited war in
Europe would be all right,
it wouldn't get any objection
because the Soviet Union
wouldn't be harmed,
they wouldn't complain,
we wouldn't be harmed,
we wouldn't complain,
the European nations wouldn't complain
because they wouldn't exist any longer.
Well, of course, the fact
is that even a limited war
with the radioactive fallout,
to the dust thrown up
in the air that might prevent
the sun shining through
for a long time, smoke
from the forest fires
that might hinder the growth of plant life
on the surface of the
earth, all over the earth
for months or years, and
the radioactive fallout
spread all over the world, the carbon-14
that has a half life of 5,070 years,
and continues to damage human beings
would continue if they existed
for tens of thousands of years.
These events, even in
a limited nuclear war
involving, say, only a thousand
times or a hundred times
the explosive power of
the Second World War,
might well mean the end of the human race.
So, we need to have a change in thinking
that Einstein talked about.
- And why, I still want to understand
why this hasn't come about.
In other words, did
these efforts of the 50s
and early 60s fail to win
the bulk of public opinion
in this country, I mean,
did the issue sort of recede
into the background and
more immediate issues
like the Vietnam War,
for example, and so on,
because when you go through this material,
from the period when you
were so actively involved,
so much of it resonates
with what we're hearing now
and in some ways, it's bothersome
that it's as if we haven't
learned the lessons
that were very clear
from the very beginning.
- You know, statements,
we were making statements
of this sort, especially,
when the stockpiles
of nuclear weapons got up to 600 megatons,
a hundred times, this was very early,
a hundred times the Second World War,
and it seemed that it
already was irrational
to have such destructive power.
Then they got to 6,000,
perhaps even to 60,000.
Estimates now are usually around 30,000
as the total stockpiles,
but that order of magnitude.
It was really, as Philip
Morrison said, insane
for the human race to have developed
the powers of self destruction
to this level, and why?
Well, back 25 years ago, 20 years ago,
the bomb test treaty went into effect.
This was in the period, looked as though
there was some sanity
coming into the situation.
There was a period of detente
and then, of course, the decision was made
to contain communism by participating
in the war in Korea, and then in Vietnam.
Not very successful efforts
to contain communism,
and the wrong kind, I think.
How much money we waste on
militarism in the world,
something like 600 billion dollars a year,
equal to the total
income of more than half
of the people in the world.
A terrible waste, think
of what good could be done
if we were not to expend so much money.
There are great problems
to be solved in the world,
to be attacked, the
problem of overpopulation,
the problem just of feeding people
is going to be more and more serious
when encroachment on the environment,
possible catastrophe from
damage to the ozone layer
and so on, and we aren't
cooperating in solving them.
The United States and the Soviet Union,
even if they were to be cooperating
in solving these problems,
would have and will have
in the future, a pretty difficult time,
and when they are fighting each other
in the ways that they are, wasting money
on militarism, senseless militarism,
there's not much chance of
solving these other problems.
I'm asked from time to time, am I hopeful?
And I say, I am, I
believe that we are going
to get through this difficult
period that we are in,
that rationality will
come into the conduct
of world affairs and I have evidence.
If I weren't hopeful, why
should I be spending my time
going around, making television interviews
and giving talks, popular
talks and traveling around,
working for world peace, if
I didn't think we'd succeed,
I might as well be enjoying myself,
reading the physical
and chemical literature
and trying to solve some
of the interesting problems
about nuclear structure
and molecular structure
and even about the vitamins
and their interaction
with the human body and
trying to find some way
of decreasing the amount of
suffering caused by disease.
So I believe that we are
going to be successful.
The fact that I believed 25 years ago
that we were going to be
successful rather soon
doesn't keep me from believing now
that we are going to be successful.
And the fact that there hasn't been a war
between the United States
and the Soviet Union
in the 25 years, leads me to believe
that the nuclear deterrent
really does work,
it does work, it's insanely
high, overdeveloped,
but it works, and the danger
is that it will cease to work
because of some accident, and
that this would be the result
of our poor sense in
continuing to make the system
more and more complicated
instead of trying to simplify it
and getting it under control.
- In your book, No More
War, you discuss how science
had become the handmaiden of war.
Really helped to think about war,
to define new instruments of warfare,
and to define new strategies,
and you propose, in that book,
that science more and more
become a handmaiden of peace,
really, that an international
research organization
for peace studies, that would deal
with many of the problems
you just discussed,
should be instituted and so on.
I wonder if you might reflect on that now.
As you probably know, the
University of California
is going through a process now,
of evaluating what it should be doing
in the realm of peace studies and so on,
and I wondered if you
would share your thoughts
with us on that issue.
- Well, there are a number of
rather small peace research
institutes and institutions
that have been set up.
Some contribute very little,
like the Hoover Institution
on War and Peace at Stanford
that doesn't pay much attention
to world peace, it seems to me,
or the United States
government's disarmament
and, I've forgotten the rest of it.
- The Arms Control Disarmament Agency.
- [Both] Arms Control
and Disarmament Agency.
- It seems to me to contribute little
directly to world peace.
My idea on it, this could
be a government function,
may not be a very reasonable one.
It may be better to get it as far
as possible away from governments.
I envisage the large
place where there would be
essentially, like a great university,
a very great university,
where the staff members
would be interested in world peace,
and would devote part of
their time to striving
to solve the problem of
eliminating war from the world
and planning out a better world
and that they would also
be productive scholars,
working on problems,
perhaps basic problems
in fields of science, or
problems of applied science
that would help in the
question of overpopulation
or damage to the environment
and all the others.
Some of them, sort of, futurists
trying to plan the future.
I think it would be fine if
the University of California,
I think Harvard has a rather small group
that might be described in this way,
that would be fine if there were a large
and effective group in the
University of California.
Here we have a university that I have,
from time to time, ever since 1945, '48,
when I was Eastman Professor at Oxford,
described as the greatest
university in the world,
and I still think of it in this sense.
The University of
California needs to continue
to lead the world, and what we need
more than anything else is to
lead the world toward peace.
- Do you feel that science
in this postwar period
has been corrupted by its
relationship to the government
and its relation to weapons programs?
- No, I don't think so.
There's misuse of science, in my opinion,
all this weaponry stuff
is a misuse of science.
Individual scientists have been tempted
into working for the
government, working on weapons,
either directly or indirectly.
I've seen the statement that
half of American scientists
are involved in one way or another.
- [Harry] Yes, I saw
that the other day, yeah.
- Yes, well, it would be
better if most of them
were working for the
welfare of human beings
in one way or another,
and there's plenty of work
to be done, we haven't
exhausted the problems,
the scientific problems.
Individual scientists, I
have said that I don't think
that the scientists could get together,
all of them, and decide that
they would not work on weapons,
that they would not
work for the government.
This would mean that we were instituting
an oligarchy of scientists.
I think that the country, the world,
should be run by the people as a whole,
not by any small group, not
by an oligarchy of scientists.
- What about the problem of
science in the Soviet Union
and the problem of science
and peace movements
in the Soviet Union.
I wonder if you would share
your thoughts with us.
One can compare, for example, your career
and your harassment by the government here
with the situation of a
Sakharov, for example,
or with the suppression, recently,
of a burgeoning peace movement there.
I wonder if you would share
with us your views on that?
- Well, I was harassed, of
course, in a less blatant way
when my passport was refused at the time
that the Royal Society of London
had arranged a conference of scientists,
a two day symposium on the alpha helix
and the pleated sheets, on
my idea, so I was to speak.
- [Harry] Very directly
related to national security
- I was the first speaker,
and the second speaker
was my associate, Professor Corey,
and then there were talks from people
from many countries
over the next two days.
I wasn't there, because my
passport was withheld from me
on the grounds, so far,
the statement was made
that not in the best interests
of the United States,
also a statement that my
anti-communist statements
hadn't been strong enough,
so I didn't get to go,
to see the X-ray photographs
taken by Rosalind Franklin,
which I would have seen
if I had gone to London
on that occasion, and
others I was prevented
from attending, various
scientific congresses,
and, of course, I was threatened
by the internal security
subcommittee of the
Senate with a year in jail
for contempt of Senate,
when I was being harassed
by the internal security subcommittee.
Well, things aren't so bad,
I wasn't treated so badly
as Russian scientists are treated.
I think of Russia, the first time I went
to the United States in 1957, I thought,
that this is something
like Oregon in 1907,
my early memories as a
boy and youth in Oregon,
the simplicity of the people,
the simplicity of the life.
And I think the Soviet
Union just lags behind us
in the way that it treats
individual human beings, too.
We aren't trying to help them to catch up,
we try to hinder them in whatever way
we can to catch up with us.
When I was invited by the
Supreme Soviet last month
to come to the Soviet
Union to help celebrate
the 60th anniversary of the
founding of the Soviet Union,
and I'm sure I was invited
because I had been given
the international Lenin
Peace Prize 10 years after
I got the Nobel Peace Prize.
When I was invited to come, I got there,
and I gave them a list of the
people that I wanted to see,
including Sakharov, that
I wanted to talk with.
I didn't get to see Sakharov.
I may have if, I had
said I would say 10 days.
After six days, I got sort of bored.
It was the 23rd of December and I thought
of two of my children and their spouses
in California, and
grandchildren in California,
and I started wanting to get back.
I came home four days
early, and gave up on,
I didn't see, didn't go ahead
with the last of my program.
So there's room for a lot of improvement
in the Soviet Union just as there is room
for a lot of improvement
in the United States
in the human rights issue.
An important issue in human
rights, it seems to me,
is the basic human right of having a job,
contributing to the work of the world,
feeling pride that you
are part of the human race
and are doing your part
in keeping the human race
going, doing work that needs to be done.
And yet, here our system
depends on having millions,
over 10 million now,
American people, out of work.
This is a great violation of human rights,
the rights of the individual human beings,
so there's something
wrong with our system,
well, there's a lot wrong
with the Soviet system.
In my book, No More War, in 1925, I said
that I foresee that with
cooperation between our nations,
working to solve the
problems of the world,
these systems will change, develop,
incorporating into each the
better features of the other,
until finally, I hope, we'll have a world
in which each human being
is able to lead a good life.
There aren't many people in the world
who lead really good lives now.
- One final question, if you look back
at your involvement in the peace movement
and your experiences in politics,
are there any lessons that you learned
about things that you
would've done differently,
or things that you think you did right,
that you think show an example for people
presently involved in the movement?
- Well, one problem that
my wife and I experienced
in the peace movement, 25 years ago,
in that period, or 30 years ago,
is that of difficulty in cooperation.
We were not active members
of peace organizations
to any very great extent, she
and I worked by ourselves.
We arranged, in 1961, an
international conference
of 60 scientists from 15 countries in Oslo
to discuss the issue of
spread of nuclear weapons.
It was a conference against the spread
of nuclear weapons, we
got out a good report,
giving the reasons for this.
And I was pleased that President Kennedy,
again, seemed to me to have
cribbed from this report
when he gave his speech against
the spread of nuclear weapons.
We included in this
statement, which was signed
by all 60 scientists, a
statement that loyalty
to ones' own nation is not enough.
We now need to be loyal to
the human race as a whole.
I was afraid, when this
statement was written,
that the three people
from the Soviet Union,
and perhaps others, two or three others
from behind the Iron Curtain,
wouldn't sign this statement,
but they did sign the statement
that we need to have loyalty
to the world as a whole.
Patriotism is not enough.
Well, not only patriotism,
but anti-communism
caused trouble in the peace movement.
We went to a peace movement in Oxford,
where my wife and I represented ourselves.
We came under our own
steam, with our own support
as we did with many,
most of these activities,
such as our supporting the symposium
against the spread of nuclear weapons.
And representatives of many
organizations came there.
The British had invited representatives
from the World Peace Council to come.
The Americans refused, and they managed
to prevent the peace meeting
in Oxford from taking place.
We were there, the others were
there, and it was stopped.
So, because and there
were other occasions too,
where it was said that we must be careful,
not join together with
groups that are dominated
by communists or by
communist sympathizers.
Our policy was that we
would sign statements
that expressed what we believed, no matter
who else signed the statements.
When Senator Hennings of Missouri,
held a hearing in which he was checking
on the passport office
of the State Department,
I was called in to
testify about my passport
being withheld, and the
Assistant Secretary of State
in charge of passport
affairs was there to testify
before the Senate committee.
He was asked, "How did it
happen that Professor Pauling
"received his passport to
go, in 1954, to Stockholm
"to get the Nobel Prize in chemistry?
"Did he appeal, was there an appeal?"
And the Assistant Secretary of State
said, "Well, there was a sort
of self generating appeal."
And here, I've just got some documents
from the State Department several years
after I wrote in under
Freedom of Information Act,
a correspondence in which
the State Department
officials are discussing
whether it would do more damage
to the United States
to refuse to let me go
to get my Nobel Prize or
to let me go to get it,
and they decided it was better
to let me go to get the Nobel Prize.
Well, here, the fact that they objected
to my traveling abroad
because my anti-communist
statements are not strong enough
indicates how important this matter
of being an anti-communist is.
In the peace movement too, here we want to
have peace with the Soviet Union,
but we don't want to talk with anyone else
who wants to have peace,
so long as we think
that he is too friendly
to the Soviet Union,
or we don't want to talk
with the World Peace Council,
which is thought to be dominated
by the Soviet Peace Committee.
We gave our public lecture in
Moscow to a thousand people
under the auspices of the
Soviet Peace Committee,
but this didn't mean, well,
to go on with Senator
Hennings, Senator Hennings
said, "Your suggestion," speaking
to the Assistant Secretary
of State, "that the Paulings, Dr. Pauling,
"was following the
Soviet line may be wrong.
"Perhaps the Soviets are
following Dr. Pauling's line."
(Harry laughs)
- Dr. Pauling, on that note, and I think
that the example of your leadership,
it really points to the
way that we can move
beyond that particularism,
that nationalism
that you're talking about
toward a universalism.
Thank you very much for
sharing your example
with us and for the future.
Thank you very much for being with us,
and thank you very much for joining us
- [Announcer] On A
Conversation with History.
(perky music)